the top contenders in the Democratic
presidential race will debate tonight
the first big test for Mike Bloomberg's
campaign the former Republican mayor of
New York will be one of six candidates
on stage in Las Vegas he qualified for
his first debate with a strong showing
in the polls but a new ABC News
Washington Post national poll this
morning shows senator Bernie Sanders
building a large lead over his rivals
former Vice President Joe Biden is still
in second place but he has shed half of
his support from a month ago
Bloomberg is now in third place Nikole
Killion is in Las Vegas for us covering
campaign 2020 no coal good morning it's
been a while since Bloomberg has been on
a political debate stage how is he
preparing tonight yeah that's right Tony
the last time was back in 2009 but we do
know that the Bloomberg campaign has
already done a walkthrough of the debate
hall even though he was just added to
the lineup and campaign aides also tell
us that former and current staffers have
been helping him to prepare by standing
in for some of his Democratic rivals who
he'll face off against tonight I don't
think he has the right to buy this
election candidates previewed their
lines of attack against Michael
Bloomberg during a town hall last night
we've been going to states like Nevada
and actually meeting the voters and
having them quiz us and ask all kinds of
things and put our policies out there
and I think that's what a presidential
candidate should do Bloomberg has
bypassed the first war early States no
big donors no special interests nothing
and is spending an unprecedented 415
million dollars of his own money on ads
throwing colossal sums of money on
television shows you what's wrong with
our system polling shows that so far
Bloomberg's unconventional approach
isn't hurting him mr. Bloomberg but it's
been more than a decade since Bloomberg
has competed in a debate we have brought
people together and I want to keep doing
that and Bloomberg's facing renewed
scrutiny about past policies he
supported that unfairly targeted
minorities his policies humiliated and
offended hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people are and I think that
is something that is worthy of
discussion
so a big issue for voters health care
last night a union member raised concern
that Sanders plan would strip hard-won
benefits when unions negotiate what is
the major issue that's up for
negotiation whether or not they're going
to take back some of the healthcare
benefits you want a 3% raise okay we're
going to cut your health care and
Peabody Church addressed president
Trump's latest Medal of Freedom
recipient Rush Limbaugh's comments but
America is not ready for a gay president
sorry but talking about my marriage is
it's never involved me having to send
hush money to a porn star after cheating
on my spouse as for Bloomberg his team
is ready for any potential criticism he
could face tonight his campaign said the
billionaire will sell off his business
if he's elected Gail
all right Nicole thank you very much